aujourd'hui nous lançons des tests
sérologiques dans disait pas du
département nous faisons le point là
fabrice men et si les directeurs des
panneaux disque effectivement ça leur
apporte la possibilité d'une
organisation différente dans leur ai pas
dit eh bien ces tests vont être élargis
mais le début de la semaine prochaine
aux autres c'est pas du département on
meurt du coc vide mais l' isolement
aussi affecte fortement et notamment les
personnes âgées
l'idée c'est évidemment pas de
déconfinement n'aime pas question il
faut également congard des
gestes-barrières qu'on garde du masque
aussi mais c'est quand même de redonner
une certaine vie sociale c'est chaque
directeur d'ehpad qui décidera pas ça
fait 15 jours que nos résidents sont
inclinés en chant ça fait quinze jours
qu'ils ne manquions elle a mangé qui ne
boit plus d'autres résidents qui n'ont
pas de vie puisque l'établissement est
fermé et pour certains ça commence
vraiment apaiser certains ne mangent
plus
17 vouloir se laisser mourir et donc
pour nous il était vraiment temps et au
rire les salles à manger pour les trois
repas de leur proposer des collations
notamment m tvo dans le jardin sur les
terrasses d'organiser des animations par
petits groupes et d'éviter effectivement
cette solitude entre le personnel c'est
pareil on a créé plus de 96 ce test
nasale on a un agent qui est positif et
qui n'a pas de symptômes
mais l'intérêt c'est de savoir également
si des personnes ont été au contact de
malades ont développé des anticorps les
permettre effectivement peut-être de
lever toutes ces grandes mesures de
précautions complémentaires quand on
comprend peut-être inutilement les tests
nous allons effectuer sont les tests
sérologiques ce sont des tests qui m'ont
permet de déterminer si
la personne prese présente ou non des
anticorps contre les coronavirus c'est à
dire si la personne a été en contact
avec le corps en un virus une personne
qui aurait été atteinte par le courant
l'a virus va commencer par avoir des
résultats positifs au test en
prélèvement un hasard puis ce virus va
disparaître de l'organisme l'organisme à
réagir en faisant des anticorps ce qui
est très intéressante dans la mesure où
seront donc un pensionnaire a fait un
épisode infectieux
on sait pas bien ce que c'est bon on n'a
pas pu faire le dépistage à ce moment là
on se retrouve à trois semaines
l'infection il est en bonne forme on
fait une recherche d'anticorps pour les
trous positif à ce moment là on dit il a
fait la maladie mais vide en acquérir et
maintenant à priori a priori on pense
qu'ils ne risquent plus rien